the third reset could be a reset around
what what other I and others call a mega
region which is really a grouping of
metropolitan areas a grouping of cities
and suburbs like the Great Boston New
York Washington currently i am nick
gillespie for reason TV today we're
talking with Richard Florida author most
recently of the great reset how new ways
of living and working dry post-crash
prosperity Richard thanks for coming oh
man it's great to be here you say that
we're in the midst of a third great
reset the first was the long depression
of the 1870s the second was the Great
Depression of the 1930s the first
depress the first reset gave rise to
kind of centralized cities the Great
Depression or the second reset gave rise
to suburbia what's the third reset and
what is it giving rise to what was
interesting for me and having some time
to look back at the history of periods
of crisis and transformation is really
that you know we call them depressions
and recessions we focus on the hardship
and the despair and and we tend to think
of these periods where government comes
in and transforms the economy at least
in our modern memory and that may or may
not play a role we talk more about that
but what I found is is two things really
matter one which Joseph Schumpeter
pointed out a long time ago these are
periods of tremendous creative
destruction but not just of individual
innovations and I and I tracked the
history looking at great studies their
systems of innovation that clustering
come together but the second thing I
found is they transform our economic
geography in ways that most of us don't
consider to be important and that these
massive shifts in the way we live in
work and kind of organize our cities and
then our suburbs are really the thing
which propel economic growth I've taken
a call of a kind of G a real Geographic
Keynesianism and the best example is
that the rise of suburbanization
obviously there was government spending
in the New Deal there was World War two
mobilization there was a period of rapid
innovation but in my view this suburban
phenomenon the creation of a market for
suburban houses is what really stoked
the industrial machine creating demand
for audit and that's something it's much
larger than certainly any government
policy but I mean it really takes it
takes over and transforms the economy
and as
formed it I think the part of government
policy that worked was the part and I'm
not saying it's relevant for today
either for its time the part that work
was infrastructure enabling that that
created markets is it also always the
case that you know starting in the 1870s
Americans started moving in immigrant
started moving urban areas it's about
what about 1920 when a majority of
people are living in says absolutely
right at the moment then suburbanization
really starts kicks in after World War
two what a plurality of Americans are in
suburbs since about two thousand and now
you're essentially arguing that that
model is over and we're shifting into
something else yeah and I say in the
book you know I'm not a clairvoyant
don't have any crystal ball it'd be like
trying to predict post-war America from
the vantage point of the election of
1932 but there are certain trends and
tendencies in our economy and society
that auger for a next kind of reset and
what geographers call the spatial fix so
one of the things I point out is I think
it's a false distinction we make and
we're trapped by it between City and
suburb or maybe the battle between the
area codes the bridges and the tunnels
and and what I seem to find looking back
at the history of American capitalism is
that one of the driving forces is the at
the simultaneous intensification of the
use of space perhaps at the core in the
city and the expanded use of space or
geography so what I argue in the book is
if the first reset was the reset of
urban America and big industrial cities
the second reset was the reset of
metropolitan America and the sub city
and its expanded territory the suburb
the third reset could be a reset around
what what other I and others call a mega
region which is really a grouping of
metropolitan areas a grouping of cities
and suburbs like the Great Boston New
York Washington car right you talk in
the book about connecting and you would
say the answer is high-speed rail one of
the things I learned in studying resets
is that the best and most appropriate
role of government is enabling
infrastructure that enables markets to
develop it so the investments in
electric power the investment at tata
cetacean in george westinghouse the
investments in cable cars and subway
systems and street rails enabled the
development in and around that
industrial city the investment in
highways and we could debate whether
those were good investments or not
the interstate highway system and talk
about high speed rail because this is on
the table it's part of an Obama
administration initiative to keep up
with China was one of the arguments that
he made but high speed rail there's only
about two lines in the in the world that
have repaid their capitals us all
operate at heavy subsidies intercity
highways interest in the air travel all
pay for their own Freight through user
fees why wouldn't we just build more
roads or more toll roads or revamp the
air travels first of all absolutely i
say this in the book price the damn
roads I mean to give away that valuable
space when people pay for everything
else so one thing we have to do is ease
congestion and speed I talked about this
in the book the velocity of moving
people goods and ideas but it seems to
me the only way we can effectively
stretch the boundaries of our urban
space is by achieving a faster kind of
rail travel and so my hunch is that kind
of subsidy makes sense I agree with you
i'm not sure it will pay for itself and
it Glaser and others have been nice
cost-benefit analysis but my hunch is
most of which come out i mean the i
don't want to say just because i agree
with them but the more serious ones that
really do a full accounting is that it's
it's going to be like amtrak where the
average fare is subsidized fifty dollars
a ticket or yeah and you would hope one
would hope that that level of subsidy
would encourage development and the
increase of density along the corridor
that would increase productivity and pay
for itself but i do think we're looking
at a subsidy my own hunch is if we're
going to help cities like cleveland or
buffalo or st. Louis i say this in the
book it's probably the best helping hand
we can give them to connect them to
scribe but i agree with you Nick and
i've been criticized for this i do think
it means connecting them to bigger hub
cities which are going to be the
employment options and you and I were
talking about this you were saying in
some of these cities the best option is
to have work elsewhere and people take
me detachments but i think this is true
i think that that will enable people in
Pittsburgh or Detroit to connect to
bigger employment centers and make them
in effect suburbs I do think that what
happened in the Northeast Corridor is
instructive you know when I was growing
up when we were growing up in New Jersey
they were suburbs of New York I really
do believe that Washington DC and its
Renaissance is not just a legacy of
federal spending and all of this and
that
it has become more integrated into this
large megalopolis no question I mean
during the post where you're certainly
the 60s 70s 80s the corporate
headquarters moved into New Jersey they
moved to Connecticut Westchester in a
way that they hadn't been before so I
mean there was a kind of bleeding out
you talk about the housing bubble at you
know and everybody recognizes that that
was at the center of the current
financial crisis which is part and
parcel of this great reset the
government has been trying to jack up
homeownership rates since at least the
Hoover administration what went wrong
and why is home ownership by your lights
not such a great idea well I think
homeownership played a fabulous role in
the post-war boom I mean in the way it
happens it really stoked that Geographic
keynesianism it really stoked the demand
for those houses not only houses but
cars and refrigerators and appliances
coming off the assembly line what I what
I think happened is as we were growing
this new knowledge based and creative an
idea driven economy we're doing a pretty
darn good job of growing it up until the
bubble popped and I think when the tech
bubble pop people said well what am I
going to do with this capital that's
sloshing rent oh I'll put any bricks and
mortar so this kind of perverse thing
happened and instead of investing in
productivity we began to slosh over tons
of this productivity gains in wealth
gains and we had a not only a housing
bubble we had tremendous land inflation
so I think the bubble became pernicious
and what I'm arguing for is not the end
of homeownership what I found in a
little empirical study I did was that
the places that tend to adjust the best
to the economic shocks that are most
resilient that have high rates of
innovation in business formation have
about fifty five percent of their people
being homeowners now in the US it's
about 67% the Urban Land Institute
predicts it's going to come down to
sixty two percent and if you look at the
analysis of the underwater mortgages
people are already saying when people
have no equity we're already down the 60
so we're talking about dialing back home
ownership and if you have a secure job
if you want to live in a place for a
long time for sure by your house well a
new careful you talk about how renting
say or an alternative tom ownership
allows people to be more mobile which
also means that economies are more fluid
and can adapt more easily to change
circumstances yeah and I think that's
the great success story you know my view
of America is what made America great
was mobility the ability
outsiders coming here for Economic
Opportunity and personal freedom and the
ability for people to move around this
this country in a way that no other
country that I've seen can handle it so
I think that now the home ownership is
kind of limited mobility and we have the
lowest rates of mobility since we've
tracked it so we got to get our mobility
back and I think the other thing is that
we have so much surplus housing and you
know the administration is trying to
fort not force incentivize people to go
back and refinance their home that's
proving to be a disaster one of the
ideas i have is why not turn that
surplus housing those foreclosed homes
those empty condos into affordable
rental and i noticed in miami beach of
all places the Miami Beach Community
Development Corporation is buying up
some of those condo projects and
creating affordable rental for service
workers that seems to be a sensible
thing to do today well I want to thank
Richard Florida author most recently of
the great resets for talking with reason
TV today I'm Nick Gillespie